NOW BACK TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
>> Tucker: ONE OF THE REASONS
PROGRESSIVES SAY THEY HATE
DONALD TRUMP IS BECAUSE HE LIES
A LOT.
TRUMP IS A COMMITTED LIAR.
TO PROVE THE POINT THE LEFT IS
TRYING TO CATALOG'S TRUMP
DISHONEST WE THE SCIENTIFIC
PRECISION YOU ASSOCIATE WITH
OBSESSED BASEBALL FANS OR BIRD
WATCHERS.
DONALD TRUMP MADE A TOTAL OF
13,435 FALLS OR MISLEADING
STATEMENTS WHILE IN OFFICE.
AS THE POSTPOINTS OUT THE LINE
BEGAN AT THE INAUGURATION.
PERHAPS YOU REMEMBER THIS CLAIM
WHICH OFENED OFFICIAL
WASHINGTON.
>> HERE IS A PICTURE OF THE
CROWD.
THE AUDIENCE WAS THE BIGGEST
EVER.
THIS CROWD WAS MASSIVE.
LOOK HOW FAR BACK IT GUESS.
>> Tucker: WE WON'T LIE.
THAT WAS UNTRUE.
THE CROWD AT THE 2017
INAUGURATION WAS NOT THE
LARGEST.
WHY DID THE PRESIDENT CLAIM IT
WAS?
THAT'S BECAUSE WHO HE IS.
DONALD TRUMP IS A SALESMAN AND A
BOOSTER AND A SELF-PROMOTOR AND
SOMETIMES A FULL-BLOWN BS
ARTIST.
IF TRUMP WAS NOT RICH IN REAL
ESTATE, HE COULD HAVE MADE A
FORTUNE SELLING CARS.
MOST PEOPLE KNOW THIS.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
IS LYING REALLY THE REASON THE
LEFT DESPISES DONALD TRUMP?
OR COULD BE THE PROBLEM BE THE
EXACT OPPOSITE?
THINK BACK OVER THE LAST 4
YEARS.
WHEN HAVE THE CNN ANCHORS BEEN
THE ANGRIEST?
WHEN DONALD TRUMP EXAGGERATED
HIS OWN ACCOMPLISHMENTS?
NO.
IT'S NOT WHEN TRUMP LIES, IT'S
WHEN HE TELLS THE TRUTH.
TRUTH IS THE REAL THREAT TO
THEIR POWER.
THERE IS AN UNSPOKEN AGREEMENT
IN CHARGE OF OUR COUNTRY NOT TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO IT.
THEY ARE IMPLICATED WITH ITS
DECLINE AND PROFITING FROM IT.
THEY MAINTAIN A STRICT POLICY OF
MANDATORY REALITY AVOIDANCE.
EVERYTHING IS FINE THEY SHOUT.
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH.
SHUT UP OR WE WILL HURT YOU.
TRUMP WON'T SHUT UP.
HE KEEPS TALKING.
THAT'S HIS CRIME.
THAT'S WHY THEY HATE HIM.
IT STARTED WITH HIS VERY FIRST
SPEECH AS A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
>> WHEN MEXICO SENDS ITS PEOPLE,
THEY ARE NOT SENDING THEIR BEST.
THEY ARE NOT SENDING YOU OR YOU.
THEY ARE SENDING PEOPLE THAT
HAVE LOTS OF PROBLEMS.
THEY ARE BRINGING THOSE PROBLEMS
WITH THEM.
THEY ARE BRINGING DRUGS.
THEY ARE BRINGING CRIME.
THEY ARE RAPISTS AND SOME I
ASSUME ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: TRUMP DID NOT CLAIM
THAT EVERYONE COMING OVER THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IS A CRIMINAL
BUT SOME ARE.
THAT'S TRUE.
BECAUSE IT IS TRUE, YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES ALLOWED TO SAY IT.
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT NOT EVERY
ILLEGAL ALIEN IMPROVES AMERICA
RAISES THE QUESTION.
IF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS HAS A DOWN
SIDE, WHY HAS WASHINGTON ALLOWED
SO MUCH OF IT?
THE IF THE PEOPLE IN CHALLENGE
CARED ABOUT US THEY WOULD
PROTECT OUR BORDERS.
THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY LET MILLIONS OF FOREIGNERS
TO STREAM IN TO USE OUR SERVICES
AND LOWER OUR WAGES AND IF SOME
CASES CRIT CRIMES.
-- COMMIT CRIMES.
THAT'S ALL TRUE.
TRUMP WAS ATTACKING THE
GATEKEEPERS IN THE NATIONAL
MEDIA WHO SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SOUNDING THE ALARM.
OUR SYSTEM IS ROTTEN AND CORRUPT
AND THE NEWS MEDIA ARE A MAJOR
REASON FOR WHY THAT IS.
THAT'S WHAT DONALD TRUMP POINTED
OUT.
NOT SURPRISINGLY THEY DEPIESED
HIM FOR DOING IT.
WHAT IS A BIGGEST SCANDAL TO THE
AVERAGE JOURNALIST?
THE FACT THAT MS-13 GANG MEMBERS
FLOODED INTO THIS COUNTRY FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA AND TERRORIZE
COMMUNICATES FROM LOS ANGELES TO
LONG ISLAND?
OR THE POSSIBILITY THAT SOMEONE
MIGHT COMPLAIN ABOUT THAT?
WE DON'T NEED TO GUESS THE
ANSWER.
LAST YEAR DONALD TRUMP DARED TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT MS-13.
WATCH.
>> WHEN THE MS-13 COMES IN AND
THE OTHER GANG MEMBERS COME INTO
OUR COUNTRY, I REFER TO THEM AS
ANIMALS AND I ALWAYS WILL.
>> Tucker: THE MOTTO OF MS-13 IS
KILL, RAPE, CONTROL.
YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE KNOWN THAT
SINCE DETAILS ABOUT WHAT MS-13
ACTUALLY IS AND WHAT METS DOES
HAVE RECEIVED FAR LESS MEDIA
ATTENTION THAN DONALD TRUMP'S
CRITICISM OF THE GANG.
MURDERING THE PEOPLE WITH KNIVES
MIGHT BE BAD BUT INSULTING
ILLEGAL ALIEN MURDERERS IS A
GRAVER SIN.
>> I HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM OF
THE PRESIDENT DEHUMANIZING ANY
GROUP OF PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES EVEN HARDENED CRIMINALS.
>> DEHUMANIZING OPPONENTS AND
USING ANIMAL FET  -- METAPHORS
IS DANGEROUS.
>> THIS IS WHAT THE NAZI DID.
>> WE ARE ALL GOD'S CHILDREN.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAYS ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS, THESE
ARE NOT PEOPLE, THESE ARE
ANIMALS.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER.
DOES HE NOT BELIEVE IN THE SPARK
OF DII HAVE BEE
OF DIVIHAVE BEE
OF DIVINIVE BEE
OF DIVINITY BEE
OF DIVINITY.BEE
>> Tucker: LOST IN THE HAZE WAS
ANY MEANINGFUL DISCUSSIONS OF
THE POLICY.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
TANTRUM.
IT'S A THEME IN WASHINGTON.
A SIMILAR PASSION PLAY UNFOLDED
WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS HEARD
SPEAKING ABOUT IMMIGRATION IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
DURING A CONVERSATION WITH
ADVISORS TRUMP ASKED WHY SO MANY
IMMIGRANTS COME TO THE U.S. FROM
IMPOVERISHED COUNTRIES.
SHOULDN'T WE TRY TO DRAW PEOPLE
FROM THE MOST ADVANCED
SOCIETIES?
THAT'S A REAL QUESTION.
CNN HAD TO SCREAM AT YOU TO MAKE
SURE YOU NEVER ASK THAT
QUESTION.
>> THIS IS DEEPLY OFFENSIVE
LANGUAGE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID WHY WE ARE
HAVING ALL OF THESE PEOPLE FROM
[BLEEP] COME HERE?
>> THE SHOCKING AND RACIST
COMMUNITIES ABOUT THE [BLEEP]
COUNTRY.
>> I AM NOT SURPRISED.
IN ONE WAY I AM PROUD.
I AM A PROUD [BLEEP].
>> NO, WE ARE NOT ALL CREATED
EQUAL.
NOT IF YOU WERE BORN IN A
[BLEEP] HOLE COUNTRY.
>> MY GRANDPARENTS FROM A
COUNTRY THAT WAS CONSIDERED A
[BLEEP] HOLE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: THERE IS THERE A
SINGLE LIVING PERSON WHO
DISAGREES WITH TRUMP'S
ASSESSMENT OF HAITI?
PROBABLY NOT.
NOBODY ON ANY OF THE CNN PANELS
IS RELOCATING TO HAITI.
FOR THE SAME REASON.
NO THANKS.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT PEOPLE
THINK, IGNORE WHAT THEY SAY ON
TELEVISION.
WATCH WHAT THEY DO.
NO ONE BELIEVES HAITI IS
APPEALING.
CRITICIZING HAITI IN PUBLIC
CALLS IN INTO QUESTION DECADES
OF APPROVED IMMIGRATION POLICY.
IT MUST BE FORBIDDENED LEST OUR
LEADERS BE EMBARRASSED.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
LAST YEAR AFTER THE KILLING OF
KHASHOGGI.
WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP
DISAPPROVED OF THE MURDER SAUDI
ARABIA REMAINS A U.S. ALLY.
-- HE CITED THE SAUDI
INVESTMENTS.
IF WE BROKE OUR ALLIANCE, THE
U.S. ECONOMY WOULD SUFFER AND
CHINA AND RUSSIA WOULD BENEFIT
INSTEAD.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF THE
SAUDIS, WHAT HE SAID IS TRUE.
THIS IS THE ARRANGEMENT WE HAD
WITH SAUDI FOR GENERATIONS NOW.
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON KNOWS
THAT BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM ARE
ON THE SAUDI PAYROLL.
TRUMPS CRIME WAS SAYING IT OUT
LOUD.
THE SAME IS TRUE WITH BALTIMORE.
MAYBE THE MOST DEPRESSING BIG
CITY ON THE EASTERN SEABOARD?
IF IT'S DAYLIGHT OUT, THERE IS
NO DENYING THE AWFUL REALITY OF
THE PLACE.
THIS SUMMER THE PRESIDENT TOLD
THE REST OF THE WORLD WHAT IT'S
LIKE.
BALTIMORE HE SAID IS A "RODENT
INFESTED HELLHOLE AND A CORRUPT
MESS."
ALL THROUGH.
THE LATEST MAYOR OF THE
OPPORTUNITY JUST WENT TO JAIL
AGAIN.
THE OBVIOUS FOLLOW-UP IS WHY IS
BALTIMORE SO BAD?
HOW DID IT GET SO POOR AND
HOPELESS?
PART OF THE ANSWER IS 50 YEARS
OF UNINTERRUPTED DEMOCRATIC
PARTY RULE HASN'T HELPED
BALTIMORE.
THEYING THAT -- SAYING THAT IS
EMBARRASSING TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> DONALD TRUMP MAKES IT A
RACIST DEBATE ABOUT BALTIMORE.
>> ANOTHER RACIST ATTACK ON AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEMBER OF
CONGRESS AND THE CITY HE
REPRESENTS.
>> THE PRESIDENT AS HE OFTEN IS
DISGUSTING AND RACIST.
>> HE USES THE RACIST APPEAL AND
THE BAIT AND SWITCH.
>> IN THE MOST RACIST WAY.
>> Tucker: IN WASHINGTON THE
LEADERS OF THE EPISCOPAL CHURCH
CALLED THE PRESIDENT'S WORDS
ABOUT BALTIMORE DANGEROUS.
NOTHING IN THE END CHANGED IN
BALTIMORE.
BALTIMORE REMAINED DANGEROUS.
REAL DANGER WHERE YOUR KID IS
SHOT RIDING HIS BIKE TO THE
STORE.
THAT'S WHAT LIFE IS LIKE IN THE
PHYSICAL CITY OF BALTIMORE, A
PLACE WHERE MSNBC CONTRACTORS
AND LEFT WING CLERICS FEAR TO
TREAD.
THAT PLACE IS SAD, AND DESPERATE
AND SKEWED UP.
AND NOT ONE PERSON DOESN'T THINK
IT IS.
-- TALKING ABOUT THAT MIGHT
POINT UP THEIR OWN FAILURES AND
SELFISHNESS.
WHATEVER WE DO, WE CAN'T BRING
THAT UP BECAUSE IT'S
EMBARRASSING.
LET'S JUST AGREE THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS A RACIST, LIAR AND MOVE
ON.
DID YOU KNOW HE IS UP TO 14,000